so
i will read the script and then the
as chair of the house eda committee i
find that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor a result of the
covet 19 pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67 and
the governor's emergency order number 12
first went to executive order
20 2004. this public body is authorized
to meet electronically
this is an executive session on bills
referred to the committee and scheduled
in the house calendar for today
an executive session may be held on any
bill referred to in
the committee there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if invited participate in this
meeting by the
zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary
access information has been made
available in the house calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and rsa 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call 271
3600 or email hcs
leg.state.nhws
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
all votes that are taken during this
meeting shall be done by roll call vote
and we'll start the meeting by taking a
roll call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state that there is anyone
in the room with you during this meeting
which is required under the right to
know
mr clerk representative allegro
no representative bailey representative
fellows
mr uh i'm sorry representative mr
representative bailey is here but he's
muted so he can't
okay i did not see uh there he is
uh representative bailey please on
i don't know what he's i can't tell
well he is muted but uh representative
bailey hi
present at home alone the mute is rather
tardy the unmute i mean okay
it takes its sweet time representative
fellows
okay representative fontenot
i am present at home and my wife is here
representative goalie home and my wife
representative grota um
and my family is here representative
judy
do we see representative judy anywhere
he had a morning appointment he'll be a
little late today
a little late today okay uh
give him give me a poke when you see him
please
representative lunzara i am
home and my family is in the area okay
uh
representative lekkis president in the
committee room
representative mcguire president of the
committee room representative o'brien
president i'm at home in nashua
you by yourself oh yes i am by myself
thank you
okay sorry to hear that all right
representative pearson
i'm an omnipresent i'm in manchester and
i've got
there's going to be people around but no
one of substance
did you say omnipresent that's pretty
terrific
uh representative roy it's a gift here
uh mustasso
president in the committee room
representative schmidt
thank you i am here at my home office in
dover i'm alone
representative show it hello i am here
at my home in pembroke alone
representative schultz
i am at my residence in concord my
husband gene taylor will be
in and out of the room thank you okay
the clerk is present in the committee
room
representative yakubovic president
in the committee room okay uh we're
waiting on
representative judy representative
microphone is very very quiet
for us in the in the uh
cyber space as well very hard to hear
her
okay well she did promise she'd be quiet
today so that may be
all right representative schuett yes you
have a question
uh actually i'm raising my hand to
motion if that's in order
on house bill 283 correct
okay we'll do that uh actually if you
could wait a bit
i'd like to do 128 which we
noticed as heck so we have to exact that
one today
and then uh then then we'll get to you
all right
uh okay so representative santana you
have a motion
on house bill 128 uh yes ma'am chair
moves
to uh make a motion of
past 128 uh otp
okay is there a second no second
okay do you wish to speak to your motion
i could just be brief uh the weather
modification notice
uh the statue has basically gone unused
the entire time it's it's been enacted
but if the
if one of these agencies want to start
doing weather modification
i think uh public notice is just
appropriate okay
something like this um i agree with that
the only addition is is that uh for some
people it's a touchy subject and
if we do it they'll think it's something
speaking going on if we do without
notice i think there's something sneaky
going on and just the best thing to do
is to
and i'd like to report that as requested
i spoke with the chair
of science technology and energy and he
looked at the bill and said
we don't care about notification
requirements uh
they were when they had it last year
they were concerned about the process of
weather modification
and that's why they had issues with it
this this time
it's our our bailiwicks this has nothing
to do with roswell does it
those are aliens roswell is not
in new hampshire yeah
geography impaired all right does anyone
else wish to comment on
i i would like to say madam chair that
oops
have to get myself unmuted here
you're unmuted representative schwartz
thank you
i i absolutely agree that that
we should not be tinkering with the
weather with no advanced notification
of the public uh that that
is becoming more and more uh you know
uh significant the weather fluctuations
that we're naturally experiencing
and the temptation to try to do
something about that
uh must be strong in in scientists and
technologists
but if it's going to be done we simply
cannot be
keeping the public in the dark about
this
thank you mandy a couple of members on
science and technology
representative sausage representative
mcgee
and uh we also spoke with a roger
stevenson from the union of concerned
scientists
and they all uh see no problem with this
as well so i'll be supporting it
seeing none the motion is ought to pass
by reference representative santo
nestaso
and when ready the clerk will call the
role representative wright
yes clark puts yes representative
pearson
yes representative yakovich
yes representative yes representative
allegro
okay representative lunzara yes i'm
sorry
was was representative bailey's photo
yes
representative bailey repeat your vote
please
represent bailey going once you you
wrote him well i just asked the clerk
what
what did you hear i didn't i i heard
i said yes please repeat your vote
representative bailey
i'm having trouble with the mute unmute
button yes
was my vote thank you
yes yeah don't you understand move uh
center representative center nostal yes
representative goalie
yes representative sheward
uh-oh he's he's not
okay so my vote is yes representative
schultz
yes representative fellows yes
representative fontenot yes
representative o'brien yes and the chair
yes looks like 18 to nothing
and the committee reports are due at
your earliest convenience
all right thank you very much and
actually
if you'll ex excuse us representative
shu and i'd like to take up house bill
because we have representative ammon
with us to explain his amendment
and i'd like to and he has to leave at
11.
so
okay so representative roy you have a
motion
um i'd like to move amen to bill 544
the amendment number is 2021 zero six
one one h okay
uh what were the last four places uh
zero six
one one eight seven zero six and i
and i will second them if motion is of
course ought to pass with that amendment
yes correct
okay and what we do about the amendment
first
we do adopt the amendment first yes
yes representative well i do understand
representatives
the amendment and talk about the
amendment can we hold off a
final vote until representative judy
joins us
uh this is an important bill to him and
he would like to be present on the final
vote
that should not be a problem but i would
but i did promise representative
and we'd be able to let him out after so
he can make his other commitment
yes thank you okay so the motion is
ought to pass on the amendment
and i would like to ask representative
[Music]
hammond to speak to his amendment
okay thank you madam chair thank you
members of the committee um
both here and remote um introducing
i would like to speak to amendment 611h
and this is an amendment to house bill
544.
the amendment uh cleans up a little bit
of the language
in two of the sections and then it adds
a new section to the general provisions
that would cover or exempt things like
cares act funding funding that
businesses have received during the
state of emergency
so that's just a brief overview i'll go
over
the exact changes so in
section c1
roman roman 1 in the section of
contractor
it adds language that uh
in any manner have entered into a
contract to perform a service for so it
enters that twice
to perform a service for and so this
would be
uh you know an actual service being
provided to the state
not something for pencils or uh you know
some
some supplies that's a product so
you see the difference there um
it it changes a few things in rsa 10c
colon 2 roman v
subsection a1 and it just cleans up some
of the language we got some feedback
that
so i'm on page three of the amendment
near the bottom
and i'm in section one there where it
starts the head of each agency
it strikes the word shall use his or her
authority under
so if it'll just read the head of each
agency shall
ensure that the agency aj voice and so
forth
so it strikes some of that redundant
language there and then on line three
it removes the the statement for
purposes of the section
comma training and quotes it takes that
out
because that was also viewed as
redundant and then finally that same
section
the very last line it adds the roman
numeral
to so it'll read rsa 10-c colon 1 comma
ii which is the list of divisive
concepts in the definition section
and then the last change that i
mentioned in the general provisions on
page four
it adds a new roman numeral three and
renumbers
the previous three to four
and i'll just read that for the record
it says nothing in this chapter
is meant to include as a contract or
subcontract
certain government financial assistance
including but not limited to the taking
or receiving of loans tax credits tax
incentives tax abatements or gifts
deriving from money sent
from the federal government or agency
designed or meant
to assist during or after a declared
emergency
including but including but not limited
to health weather
riot civil disobedience or acts of
foreign agents
or designed as economic stimulus during
economic emergency
so there was a uh there was a summer
camp for kids
that raised this issue um they received
care money
would this bill affect them and so that
that provision was put in
to exempt uh situations unusual
situations like we've had this last year
so that if the state was distributing
money designed as stimulus
or uh you know to make a business hole
for having to shut down because of
emergence
that they'd be exempted from from this
so that that concludes my explanation
okay are there any questions for
representative
i have a question madam chair yes
representative schmidt
thank you uh representative amman if you
i i don't i'm not
seeing the language that you have just
read to us
uh in the copy that i was sent so i'm
just
questioning you as you were reading it
you used the word
i couldn't tell whether you were saying
insure or
ensure and i just want to make sure that
uh
that we have we don't use the word
insurer
which has two meanings in english the
more common being
uh not the desired meaning here
so does the copy read ensure
it doesn't use either word actually oh
yeah so i'm speaking to i'm speaking to
the amendment um
which is a single page document right
the section he was reading is line 17
through 22 on the amendment
and i don't see the word insure or
ensure i think i may have used the word
ensure
so that was uh is that is that the
correct use of the word
yes sorry online nine the head of each
agency shall
ensure that the agency oh that's great
thank you both that's that's my issue
that's line nine i have i have similar
peeves like when people pronounce the
word sandwich
and they say sandwich that just hurts my
ears when i hear that okay
representative lekkis returning to the
amendment um
is my understanding accurate that this
amendment does two things removes
redundancy and just narrows the scope
of what this this bill would apply to
other questions representative schuett
thank you madam chair um representative
eminent it appears that
uh you've made a couple of carveouts for
groups uh regarding this bill
receiving federal funds and so forth
does this not indicate to you that there
may be
further unintended consequences from
groups that just
are not aware of this bill yet
uh no it doesn't and um you know
sometimes
it's a tactic to sow doubt about a bill
to get people to
you know feel unsure of it that that uh
that amendment deals with private it
it clarifies that private uh companies
private providers of services are not
covered by this that it's only
state institutions uh which is the rsa
um chair i have a question yes
representative
thank you um representative emman the
summer camp that you referred to
where is it and what is it uh i
i'm not at liberty to say
and why is that uh because
it's uh i don't have it
uh i don't have knowledge of that exact
summer camp
uh right now i'd have to go look at
notes
follow-up please yes follow-up thank you
in my in my uh in my district we have
see the seco
science center which is a museum
it's a marine museum and a training and
a children's camp
that rents property from the state of
new hampshire ordeon point
is a state park and the seacoast science
center is located there
so would they be subject to this bill
do they perform a service for the state
of new hampshire
no then it's my understanding they
wouldn't
be well i'm i'm bringing up the camp
analogy because
now i'm curious as to yes so you're
getting
you're getting focused on a camp but
what what the amendment the amendment
doesn't deal with camps it deals with
any business including restaurants
all the businesses that have received uh
money
because of the covid situation that's
what that
that uh that new section to the build
does is it
says even though you receive state money
because of a state of emergency
that this would not apply to you because
you're not doing uh business
for the state in your normal course no
has nothing to do with summer camps it
has to do with
just about every business in our state
who's received money because of uh
you know cares act funding funding for
employees and payroll because of covid
because of the state of emergency
that's what that deals with please don't
be impatient with me because my
questions are sincere
and i can fixate on camps because that
is my constituent
and i want to be sure that they are not
um
they are not put in a bad position
because of this bill
so my questions are sincere and they are
directly related to
a important constituent in my community
yeah i responded fine but yeah
well i hope that his assurance that
since the camp
that you were or that you refer to is
not performing a service for the state
they are not covered by the bill that's
fine that's all i need to know thank you
representative thank you madam chair
okay are there any other questions from
okay then thank you very much for your
help in this bill
thank you thank you everyone all right
is there any
well that's extraordinary in that case
the motion is ought to pass on amendment
zero
six one one h to house bill 544
what to adopt yes
representative pearson yes
representative jakobovic
representative lekkis yes representative
allegro
yes representative bailey
representative uh uh lanzaro
yes representative santo nestaso
yes representative goalie
yes on the amendment uh representation
yes on the amendment that's what we're
doing the amendment
uh representative judy is not yet here
or is he here
uh all right sam well i'm just
checking representative schmidt
yes on the amendment uh represent
representative schultz no no
representative fellows yes on the
amendment
representative
yes
representative grota yes
representative o'brien yes
the chair yes looks like 17 to 1.
right that's it the amendment is adopted
and as requested we will
uh not continue with this bill until
representative judy is here
thank you madam chair no trouble yes
so representative schuett has a motion
yes ma'am chair uh i would move
amendment 0540h
okay did you explain your amendment
yes um i spoke with the
the chair the prime sponsor i'm sorry
and um she appreciates the fact that
there is
reticence in our committee to uh
put anything more into the statutes
naming days and since
this is in fact coming up on the
275th anniversary
of mr cheswell's birth it seemed to me
that it was a rather important
anniversary to recognize so i had the
amendment drafted
to just proclaim this for the one
day for this year and
i would further request madam chair we
adopt this amendment
and pass the bill if there's any way
that we could
attempt to expedite the house's action
on it uh as we're coming up close to the
deadline date
i'm sorry the the actual date of the
celebration
okay in response to my second i would
say that
wentworth chaswell was definitely worthy
commemoration and
i hope that the town of newmarket will
honor him every year because that's the
most appropriate place for it
um i don't know when the house will next
meet but
i would suggest that we'll we get this
out of our committee and over to the
house so that
it can be passed at the earliest
opportunity
i would appreciate that thank you madam
chair okay
does anyone else have anything to say
represent scitec um
sure but there's a bigger picture here
because
we have own owner judge
stains also and i
really would like to discuss both of
these together
uh because i like the idea of naming
the uh the building at peas after
after this man actually uh
i've sort of been concerned that my
education has been 15 minutes
on this and i'd like to get more
comfortable with it but i really want to
go in this direction
i've no i'm not really discussing this
amendment i'll stop at this point but
there's a bigger picture here is
yes i think we can discuss naming the
airport terminals
under the other bill we will note that
you prefer
uh mr chisel uh representative schmidt
thank you madam chair and i too want to
second your remark
uh since we've heard that mr cheswill um
is going to uh have a statute in new
market
and he was a citizen of some note uh
there for his virtually his entire
career
so i'm i'm glad to learn about him had
never heard of him before but i think
it's
significant and i would like to see the
uh
the commemoration uh happen
this day uh this year and
on the 275th anniversary if we can
manage it but
uh but i agree with you that the the new
market statute
statue is the appropriate uh
you know long-term um
honoring of this gentleman okay
okay seeing none the motion is to accept
amendment
zero five four zero h to house bill 283
the clerk can call the roll
representative right yes
represent the clerk votes yes
representative pearson
yes representative yakubovic
yes uh representative yes
representative allegro yes
representative bailey
yes uh representative lonzara
yes representative santo anastasia yes
representative goalie yes representative
yes representative schmidt
yes representative schultz
yes representative fellows yes
representative fontenot yes
representative grota
yes representative o'brien yes
the chair yes 18 to nothing
with the amendment adopting the
amendment and representative
you have a motion yes madam chair i move
that
house bill 283 be adopted with the
amendment
yeah i'm happy to defer to
representative pearson
all right thank you representative
pearson
very good is there any further
discussion
i think we've probably uh covered
everyone's
opinion uh the only thing i will say i'm
sorry that
representative judy has not made it back
to be able to
vote on this i'm sure this would be of
great import to him also
okay well he can bask in the glow of a
committee recommendation
right the motion is ought to pass with
amendment on house bill
283 and the clerk can call the roll
representative roy
enthusiastically yes the clerk votes
yes representative pearson
yes representative yes
representative yes representative
allegra
yes representative bailey yes
representative foley okay great thank
you representative
enthusiastically yes and the shadow
votes yes
representative schmidt yes
representative schultz yes
representative fellows yes
representative
yes representative broda yes
representative o'brien yes
and chair yes no
thank you and uh madam chair i should
have
i will forward it as quickly as possible
thank you very much very appreciative
um anyone object to consent
okay seeing none we'll put it on consent
moving right along i moved to retain
house bill 170
commemorating the first labor strike in
the u.s by women
and
[Music]
i'm
i'm moving that because we are we have a
very
severely limited amount of time
in session due to the difficulties
of arrangements and um
and so we we have been asked not to pass
or not not to move to the floor anything
that we think will have a debate if it's
not a
vitally important bill and i think this
qualifies as not vitally important
since it was 1828 this is isn't even a
specific
timing for any any uh anniversary it
will be just as valid to declare this
starting next year
so i suggest to billy routine
madam chair i also have a point i'm
sorry representative pearson
uh the other thing doing a little
research the the bill is actually
historically inaccurate the first labor
strike that was done predominantly
by women was done in pawtucket rhode
island in may of 1824.
oh madam chair i actually
think that this has been debated by
historians
and the majority say
uh representative schultz how can 1828
be before 1824
the nature of the uh labor dispute
as i understand it it's sort of like
when
when people claim to have invented the
cheeseburger in a way
a lot of places claim to have invented
the cheeseburger do you know what i mean
like
but the historic historians say the
first one is the one
in new hampshire because of the um
it the extent of the uh labor dispute
compared to what happened in rhode
island
is um wasn't an extensive labor
union that gives me even more reason to
say we should postpone this debate if
the
historians argued representative schuett
yes madam chair i'm just kiss um
is this an attempt to enable new
uh again i think that if we want to
i think we need to to look into this a
little further and
i don't have the time to to work on it
this year
all right representative goalie
thank you manager uh madam chair
you know as well as i know that we get
four or five
maybe sometimes six bills each year
looking to name days
for the governor to proclaim on a yearly
basis there's currently a
list that is growing every year in
statute
and i i think sometimes it's a
disservice for some of those because
if you look at the list most people
don't know what those days are or are
unaware of them so i'm not sure that
they
actually do what they're
intended to do and you know i think it's
nice that the governor proclaimed maybe
once or twice
to get something kicked off and then the
organization
keeps the ball rolling so i will support
the retain because uh
i think it's just a little going a
little too far thank you
yes well if if uh you think we should be
killing this bill instead i'm okay with
that too
representative i'll have what
actually that that's a good point if i
uh
representative schmidt you have your
hand raised i do madam chair
um being a representative of dover and
uh i would
like to point out to the committee and i
in support of uh your motion to
retain the bill and especially in light
of this
somewhat insert uncertainty as to
whether rhode island was first and so
forth
uh city of dover has actually already
had a celebration
and there was a video created
that was quite instructive with regard
to this
event it's something that the city of
dover clearly
thinks is is of significance and we may
find in
in our treatment of it in the retention
period
uh that we come to understand and
and also firm up the
historical accuracy um and perhaps even
see the video so
uh i'm in favor of the retention motion
thank you remember
you know this is not going to be
pleasant but i'm going to say it
the fact is we gave pollyanna day or
whatever that thing is
and this is far more significant as far
as i am concerned the first
women's strike even though not
successful
or uh walk out whatever
this is this deserves some kind of real
commemoration
if we're going to do pollyanna well i've
what he said all right well that's
fine i like since there's not a strong
um
opinion in favor of vote to pass but
we'll retain it representative
schmidt will do some research in dover
and
i will happily okay um madam chair i do
have a question i'm sorry
is my hand not raised i yes it is sorry
i
didn't that's okay that's okay i just
want to make sure that my hand is raised
um thank you i just want to make sure
that and i'm sure that you're
that you're able to manage this but i
just want to be sure that if we retain
bills we're going to work on them
and i'm concerned that the number of
bills that we retain so far
so that what are your plans on are we
are you going to put subcommittees
together to work on these bills what do
you have plans on
i've set up subcommittees already and
in most cases we'll i'll assign the
bills after crossover because i don't
think we'll be retaining any senate
bills
once we get the get through crossover
we'll set it up
and i think that the
subcommittees ought to meet relatively
soon
like in april or may to make a plan for
the bills
okay and this one i think the
subcommittee is going to say
representative schmidt give us a report
in october and uh we'll vote on it then
um others will take more work by more
people
yes i'm especially concerned about the
daycare bill the daycare
so exactly that one will take some
serious work
right okay thank you so much okay
representative schultz
uh am i unmuted yes you are um
just to be clear the afl-cio says
that the first union created by women
working women
was the lowell female labor reform
association
and that this was the first strike
the afl cio says that i just wanted to
clarify
marvelous we will have a history lesson
when we get back to this
representative representative grote is
this a question for you do you have any
and i can take my computer with me
that'll help with the research okay the
motion is to retain
house bill 170 and uh
seeing no further discussion but clerk
representative roy yes represent the
clerk what's yes representative pearson
yes representative jacob yes
representative alexis yes representative
allegro yes representative bailey
yes representative lonzara
yes representative santa anastasia yes
representative goalie yes representative
yes representative schmidt
yes representative schultz yes
representative fellows yes
representative funknow
yes representative grota yes
representative o'brien yes the chair
yes 18-0 okay
chain bills don't have to go on consent
the house doesn't get a vote until
january
one other uh thing is that i was
thinking about the emergency power
spills
and i've come up with a bit of an
amendment to
house bill 217 that i'll be uh
distributing to the committee for
comment
um it's not ready to vote on yet but i
would appreciate any comments that you
have
217 or 417 417
sorry i may have misspoken
all right do you have those uh exact the
green
exact same yes i do i don't think you
take one
all right we i don't see representative
judy yet so we will not do that one
a little crinkly all right
not there uh let's in that case we
should
represent a scitec you have a motion on
house bill 273
all right can we please have a refresher
course on what is the title of house
bill 273 please
[Music]
and this one is time critical so it's
ought to pass progress on scitec
seconded by representative roy
he would just speak to your motion
briefly and that is that
it's hard to think of more significant
events in our
constitutional republic or amendments
that were made this is a
significant i'm not a big fan of days
and memorials but this is a one-time
thing it is i can't it's a very it's
hard to think of something that trumps
this
uh maybe i don't use that verb that's uh
better than this
uh so i i think the i think the
memorial day is fitting
firsthand ferrari uh i would just uh
adopt representative sites okay so
anyone else wish to comment
[Music]
um yes representative yes thank you
madam chair
um i'll just state that
i believe that representative scitec um
schmidt and i probably all
started voting well before this age was
lowered
so i think it's an important thing to
recognize
that this enabled a lot more of our
citizenry
to chime in on issues of national
importance
at the risk of exposing my age i turned
18 that summer
and voted in the local elections in 1971
i can't remember anything before high
school so it doesn't matter
i graduated in high school that year so
let's uh talk about
that if i may yeah i just want to add
that
it's important today as it was then um
but
at that particular time i think they had
a lot of importance
um because we had young people serving
in in vietnam
who were old enough to serve but not old
enough to vote
and we as a society decided to correct
that and
pour drink or drink indeed yes actually
the trekking age was wasn't lowered
until uh
the next year yeah that was all thank
you
okay anyone else have a comment
representative allegro
i remember this debate at the time and
even though i was a very young man
i never understood the logic of being
able to send people off
to war without giving him the
opportunity to
uh vote on those sending them and to
have a beer when they got home
however i do have to say that if we had
a memorial or a day for every single
wrong that we corrected in our 200 plus
year history
uh we would be even more inundated than
we are now so i'm
i'm not in favor of this but i i'm in
it is a one-time event oh
and i would also say that my first duty
station was west germany
i was 18 and uh the drinking age did not
matter to me
representative allegro is going to be
heading up the subcommittee on enlarging
it's a special treat okay so the motion
is ought to pass
on house bill 273 made by representative
scitex
and when ready the clerk can call them
representative roy
yes representative the clerk votes yes
spoke
representative pearson
yes representative
yes representative yes representative
allegro
yes representative bailey yes
representative lunzara yes
representative santos
yes representative goalie
yes representative showed yes
representative schmidt yes
representative schultz
yes representative fellows yes
representative fontenot yes
yes representative o'brien yes
the chair yes 18 to nothing all right
does anyone object to consent
yes madam chair um and it'll be on the
i may i um are we going to vote on the
yet on the consent it was the only one
person i just think
in light of only one person any one
person can take something off consent
so one person is all that's needed to
keep it from going on consent in the
first place
what was the final ask my colleague to
reconsider
since uh our days in the house
are very long and i don't really think a
floor debate on this is necessary
i would say that with a that with an 18
to nothing committee recommendation
the chances of a floor debate are
minimal
well i'd like to point out that the lead
sponsor of the bill is the democratic
leader
and this is a wonderful moment of
bipartisanship
and i know the speaker is seeking those
moments as well
and i'm so happy to see a bipartisan
support for you
for 18 to 20 year olds voting
it probably won't be a long thing on the
house floor but it is
isn't it nice to have so no i'm not
withdrawing my
your that's not a problem representative
fellows
um yes madam chair i i just wanted to
point out that
the date that we're trying to celebrate
is may
13th of this year
and that's not very far away if it's on
the consent calendar we know
the first day that the house meets it
will pass and it can go on
and if it's not on the consent calendar
we might not even get to it in those
three days
or we'll get to it in the last of the
it's fortunately we're relatively early
in the alphabetical order so
it's likely to come come up on the first
day
in fact last uh last session we
our bills came up before launch for the
first part
and yes we'll do our best to make sure
it's efficiently handled
and madam chair i just want to add i
totally respect the remarks you made at
the beginning of our exact session
about what the consent calendar does
etc and i'm mindful of all of that
i just want to say i am mindful of that
while i made
my objection to consent
that's fine representative
first a couple of sentences on the floor
uh
this is not going to take any more time
than for the speaker to read it
there's not going to be a fight but the
point that you did not make
representative schultz is this
this is in the consent calendar things
are often buried
it'd be nice that the house actually saw
this
for the brief moment that it takes
well thank you representative scitec
that's what i meant to say
all right excellent let's go on before
moving on before
we we have another uh all right
madam chair if i may just ask a question
of the chair
i'm curious i'm still not seeing
the status of house bill 130
which our committee voted on back
february 18th
and i will check and see what happened
to it thank you
and i will mention representative
schuett that i was
looking at house bill 2 and there's a
section in there that deals with that
issue
so if you would take a look at house
bill 2 and see
see if it agrees yes madam chair i did
actually
see that someone called it to my
attention
and i'm not quite sure i believe
that um that is something being put
forward by
administrative services and
uh therefore that's why i'm concerned
about
having this committee's opinion go
forward because we voted on it
before that he appeared exactly
if so if you would you would check house
bill 2 to see if it
to see how it compares and we will uh
i'll mention to uh finance that we've
already voted on house
on house bill 130 and it it should take
precedence thank you we'll see
all right next what else have we got
all right and i'm also going to move to
day
was
unless representative goalie suggests we
should just kill it but i think it would
be uh
that would involve more debate than a
retained promotion
i'll support retain okay thank you
i believe chair is it not true that um
i believe the governor does proclaim
this every year anyway does he not
uh he has on more than one occasion i
don't know every year
um i can't see that that the 111th
birthday is
more significant than the 112th it'll be
next year i mean
i agree so um
all right
[Music]
anyone else want to comment on retaining
okay seeing none the emotion is to
retain and the clerk can call the world
representative roy
yes represent the clerk votes yes
a little louder please yes
representative yes representative
yes representative allegro yes
representative bailey
yes representative lanzara yes
representative santa nastassa yes
representative goalie
yes representative yes
representative schmidt yes
representative schultz
yes representative fellows yes
representative yes representative grota
yes representative o'brien yes
and the chair yes 18
all right so uh representative allegro
you have a motion
uh yes on uh house bill 606
and that is on uh exempting um
haircutting in uh aesthetics practice
without remuneration i'd like to move
all right this is house bill 606
which we debated somewhat at our last
who was the second representative roy
thank you okay
you wish to speak to your motion yes and
i'm not going to go through everything i
went through the other day when we
actually began debate on this i'll just
simply say
that um government
intended to interfere with the personal
relationships
uh and friendly activities between
neighbors friends
and family uh meanwhile
uh the current leader structure which
this bill would alleviate
the current legal structure indicates
that it's a like i say misdemeanor for
me to cut my wife's hair
i think that's way beyond the pale um
and activity between consenting adults
or
a consenting adult and a child for whom
they have
um care and custody of
uh again it should not be interfered
with
by the government so if i choose to put
my
granddaughter's thumbnails um
lastly i hear a lot of evidence about
the uh
perils of putting chemicals in people's
hair chemicals like
head and shoulder shampoo and miss
clairol
i just don't see it as a real peril and
i haven't heard any numbers i just keep
hearing about the threat
but i've never heard a thing where
someone could tell me yes
840 people were hospitalized with scalp
burns
last year in new hampshire it's because
those numbers don't exist
so i'll just leave it at that and
if need be i can chime in again later i
i hope that
this will just be supported
representative roy
um i would uh second his um comments and
i would add one other comment um some
people
have said that you know this no one's
being arrested for cutting their child's
hair and no one's being prosecuted for
dying their girlfriends hair um
well that's true then it shouldn't be in
statute
so let's fix it okay
representative uh yes as i think
the chair mentioned we talked before um
having laws which are um
in place but are not enforced and
leaving it to the discretion of the
people enforcing it
i think is a very bad practice for a
number of reasons
and i'm very strongly opposed to it i
mean people are supposed to
be able to know what the law is and
follow the law
and you know if it's not written down
under what circumstances the law implies
in what circumstances it doesn't
that's not good um it you know maybe it
wouldn't be a big issue in this case but
it can lead to
discretionary enforcement where uh you
know law enforcement or other people
in authority can choose to apply the law
to some individuals and not others for
whatever reason
and the other thing is is if people know
that something's illegal
and they're regularly breaking the law
that does not contribute to respect for
the law either
and so for a number of reasons it's uh
it's just a very bad practice and i uh
support this bill
all right representative fought now
thank you madam chair
um i i cannot support this bill because
even though i agree with the
representatives that spoke before me
that i don't think it should be against
the law for
a mother to cut the child's hair
this bill allows me to set up a
barber shop in my driveway now and
and provide all those services for all
of my neighbors
or and strangers with no regard to any
of my skills
um uh or relationship to these other
people
so you know for that reason i think uh
i think it's the reason that we have
laws in place i also hold a
an electrician's license uh and a
realtor's license but i don't think that
people without those licenses
should be able to set up shop all over
town simply because they
are not charging a fee in my business we
uh it's clarified that compensation
um is not uh
does not make a difference on
representation so
uh whether i get paid for my service or
not i'm
still liable so for that reason i can't
support this bill
thank you from scitec a couple things
first representative front know the
chances of setting up
barbershop in your driveway or doing
massive
work for free that's a number as close
to zero as i can imagine
but there's an issue that uh even i'll
not surprisingly i'll vote for the bill
but
there's an issue here that deserves some
thought and some study
and that's if it's a matter of public
health and
safety the chemicals in the hair
uh scalper there's there's
i have to think about that i'm not
prepared it's not a crusade i want to go
on but it's something that
should be thought about because look i
can't tell you that i saw
or you would not be happy if i said i
saw a youtube video this morning and i'm
ready to take out your appendix because
you've consented
and after all it's through people i'm
not charging uh
there's something to be uh i don't know
where i'm
i know where i want to go but i don't
want to study this issue but there
are elements here you talk about public
health or safety
and you mean it as a it deserves
some thought and that's all right
representative o'brien
uh thank you madam chairman i i
agree with the debate that uh this
probably
rarely happens but uh and
i can see somebody having the opinion
that it is selective for
certain people to like enforce a law but
there's
also a point that i think we must
consider
in those situations where something
becomes
truly egregious that has occurred
where can the person fall back on
and to uh have something that is in law
that can't apply so therefore i cannot
support this
bill because i think the current law is
adequate
whether it's enforced or not but in
those egregious type of situations
it will apply a vehicle that can be used
by the proper authorities
if they deem fit that the situation was
egregious
and allow the proper legal authorities
to which i have full faith into our
prosecutorial
uh prosecutorial friends the attorney
general's office
is to determine which cases are
legitimately that can be tried thank you
representative schuett thank you madam
chair
i i sort of echo what representative
o'brien just said uh
i was actually a little disappointed i
knew um
this would probably come up again it's
been tried a few times
and i was a little disappointed that the
language came out
so similar as to has previously been
denied
i would like to see something
that would ease the case of a family
member
cutting someone's hair for example but
i think there does need to be something
in law
that would enable someone who does these
kinds of things
in a nefarious manner to be
prosecutable so i will be voting
against this so thank you representative
fellows
thank you madam chair um i think one of
the
reasons i have to vote against this bill
is that i think it opens up the
opportunity for someone to
parlor in their home and go completely
under the radar
and they can take
fees from the people they provide
services to
and if an inspector can ever find them
which
may not be the case if they don't have a
sign or they don't advertise on the
internet
then they will just they
they will just go under the radar and if
the inspector does come by they'll say
oh well i don't get paid you know i'm
just doing it for a friend
and uh the other thing that i'm
concerned about
is if we do that in this particular
statute do we have to do it in other
places also
you know for for anything that that
people
you know for putting
you know ointment on a on a kid's knee
for using um prescribed medications
under
that a doctor gives you know where do
you draw the line for this
and if the if the concern is within a
family it it ought to stay within a
family and not
for not do the remuneration
edit to this statute thank you
representatives um if someone does this
and causes someone else serious harm
there was concern that uh
there was no legal recourse i don't
think that's true because
you know in any case if you harm
somebody they're open to a civil suit
you've committed a tort against them
and so if somebody does cause serious
harm doing this there is a remedy
and uh that could also act as deterrent
from
that that possibility can act as a
deterrent from somebody doing something
particularly dangerous i mean it won't
necessarily fix all problems
but at least the person harmed would get
um i would just in response to some of
the things representative phillips said
the
um someone could do that now this law
doesn't change anything someone can open
up a secret
uh salon right now and so the law
is irrelevant to that scenario second of
all i
think that in a in a society such as
ours we you know
the the old latin phrase you know
to the buyer beware we we really need to
people let people have the decision if
someone decides you know i'm going to
have my girlfriend cut my hair
and it comes out horrible well she
should have went to a licensed
place that had it done that i mean it's
the same thing if i
have some body work done in my car by
someone who's
not licensed to train and it comes out
looking horrible i should have
not gone to them i should have paid the
extra you know you get what you paid for
it
um and in this case it's not even paid
for it's free so
i just think that at some level we have
to trust our own citizens to make their
own decisions
okay representative bailey
i believe several times fees or payment
have been mentioned where
i believe it explicitly says that this
exempts only those things provided
that's all thank you representative
goalie
thank you madam chair i just need to
um speak to the buyer beware i think
a lot of laws are on the books to
protect those that are vulnerable
um we know our elderly are specifically
vulnerable and to just use the language
let the buyer beware i don't think is
something we should be uh using as a
guideline
um i think we're here to protect those
citizens and
this is one way of doing that so
i'll be voting against this
representative
thank you madam chair um i would just
rebut
the comment of representative lakers
about
pursuing a civil suit if if you have a
problem
uh number one that that would involve a
cost
to the victim to pursue that and number
two
that's time consuming if someone is for
example
coloring people's hair uh involving
chemicals
and the problem involves damage
to the health or disfigurement whatever
that person basically could continue
doing that
if law enforcement couldn't step in
right away because of the law
in the length of time that it would take
a suit to work its way through the court
thank you representative right
i just wanted to clarify on the caveat
and tour
um the where necessary
to protect i mean first of all i don't
think our seniors are in some great risk
of world haircuts
but i i think that where it's serious
and it
it is dangerous uh to the example that
representative fought will give with
electrical codes that could cause fires
and electric
shock is different than you know getting
a bad haircut or
or and even to the and we talk about
scalp burns you can go to the store
right now
and buy products to dye your own hair at
home if we're so worried about that
perhaps we should ban those
and you shouldn't be able to do it
yourself either um it's
i mean at some point it becomes you know
so
yeah it's it's not just we're not
throwing people to the wolves and say
figure it out for yourselves but on some
issues that are
so simple as this i do not think that we
need to
exert such government oversight
representative
thank you i just want to make a comment
the products that are sold in the
grocery store
are nothing like the products that are
used in a
professional beauty salon so i think
that people need to understand that it's
not the same thing
um haircut you can tell that i don't
really
right and so basically making decisions
on things that we're not really
fully um aware of
and um what i'd like to say is if this
if this is something that's important to
the people the proponent of this bill
and there's something that they can come
up with that would make the other
the people who are opposed to bill more
palliable
such as only talking about family or or
relatives i would be open to that but as
the bill stands
i'm not in favor of it thank you
thank you madam chair uh to the comment
that
hair products yes they are sold in the
local market and everything
but also too keep in mind just because
something is available to the public
does not necessarily mean it meets the
standards that are being discussed here
uh case in point
many variety stores or other type of
shops do sell
marijuana type of pipes and devices
and uh cigarette papers that i don't
think i use for cigarettes
and as far as i know federal law and
state law still hasn't recognized the
sale of marijuana yet they
some of these by-products are available
to the public but i just want to
clarify that point uh it is a people's
choice on what to do
uh thank you mr madam chair so uh
again i'll come back to the point that
i've made in the past
that nobody's being prosecuted for
cutting their kids hair
and it's always about cutting kids hair
but there are it's a whole panoply of
services that can be provided
for nothing for free uh under
this proposed uh law and
uh this is not a problem that's that
it is causing any uh any kind of problem
it's an it's a solution in search of a
problem
um and members of long-serving members
of time
long time serving members of this
community um
will recall the instance that we had of
the the gentleman that came in uh
he and his wife had been in a mall
where somebody uh was offering free
teeth whitening
i don't believe that's relevant
representative schmidt
but the point is it was offered for free
it was offered for free and the
assumption was
because it was the person appeared was
wearing a white coat
they thought well they knew what they
were doing they were wearing a white
coat
a woman got severely burned her lips
and her gums are severely burned so
people who are messing around with
chemicals and providing
home services of this nature it's not
just hair cutting
would be you know allowed to continue
uh doing what they're doing
including free haircuts for the elderly
we heard that
testimony in committee
and so we've rejected this in the past
as a problem
and you hear that we're going to be
voting
um against this this time as well
thank you representative fellows
uh yes madam chair i was wondering if
you can
confirm does cosmetology come
include things like facial peels
that's aesthetics well
but which is also covered by this
amendment they're in that same chapter
so i just wanted to say that i've used
over-the-counter
products neutrogena on my face
that was supposed to be a moisturizer
and
it caused me to end up with something
that looked like a pretty bad
sunburn and if people are
more strong stronger
products to do chemical peels i think
that there's definitely some danger to
the
public with this because the
cosmetologists and
as anesthetists are get using
procedures that go far beyond just
haircuts
i i agree a haircut is not a big deal
but i think some of the other
things that they do can be dangerous
thank you wrapping up science i just
want to declare
war on the elderly here representative
goal you brought that up i have
excellent credentials in that department
and i don't i'll take care of myself
thanks i thank you representative
scientific representative strokes
thank you madam chair um first of all
there's a whole genre of youtube videos
that i fell
down the rabbit hole and once all about
people doing their own hair
and it's pretty funny but some horrible
results so if you're ever bored google
it
on youtube um and you may have heard of
the gorilla glue incident that was kind
of recent
but more importantly it is true
that and i will say this is
a area of uh society that maybe the
majority of guys aren't
as knowledgeable as we ladies but um
you can get mrsa from a pedicure
if you have unsterilized hair equipment
um you could even pass lice potentially
you could uh get a facial that was
really trendy a couple years ago
uh that people were doing themselves
that was giving uh other people
hepatitis
so there are a number of health laws
that
that i talked to my beautician and
esthetician about
um and certainly not all of them make
the news
but uh there is a lot to the license
that these uh service providers service
providers you know what i mean
these are beauty um workers
do who that are serious
and need uh instruction
serious chemistry serious health uh
understanding and if you've seen the
haircuts i've given my husband during
covid you would want people to
have the license and so for that reason
yes uh the reason that we talk about
haircuts
and clipping a child's fingernails is
because
as much as we would like to separate the
issues they
are lumped in under the same statutes
and so i'm not suggesting that someone
perform podiatry on somebody right you
need a license to be a physician
but i am suggesting that lumping
somebody in who files their
grandmother's toenails down
is not the same as putting dangerous
chemicals i have to say
i agree wholeheartedly with
representative fellows who
said where does it stop that's
exactly the point we've reached now
where does it stop
and where will it go if i want to lend
my friend 50 bucks
never my family member a neighbor if i
want to lend a neighbor 50 bucks
should that put me in violation of
banking rules
or should i be subject to banking rules
what about licensing
for food preparation if i want to cook a
meal for a stranger never mind a family
member
or a relative or a friend for a stranger
should i be subject to licensing rules
what about
administering medication how many times
i know i've done it countless times
have you helped a person who wasn't
capable of taking their own daily
medication
to take their medication on a daily
basis that's far more dangerous
than the chemicals we're talking about
and again the difference between
the chemicals available at a hairdresser
salon versus in your house
yeah that also includes the difference
between head and shoulders and paul
mitchell
right paul mitchell you're getting a
hairdresser so yes
there are occasions i doubt although i
haven't been
uh none have been reported to me
or presented here at this hearing or the
other day
there may be occasions when somebody
gets uh nits
or a scalp rash or something like that
but
we're still dealing with consenting
adults
and if i want my friend or a perfect
stranger
to cut my hair the government has no
place
putting their nose in my personal
private
consenting business and to answer the
last question
where does it stop do we go on to other
things i lay down the gauntlet here
thank you representative you had a
comment
yes that last i was i was going to say
something but the person before me
reinforced it
we are if you go back and listen to this
testimony
i think you're going to be very
surprised at how this has evolved from
concerns to safety to government
intervention
and that's not what we're here to do we
are not here to bring our political
agenda or
our our personal agenda to this
excuse me yes yes uh
i believe that's approaching an
inappropriate comment
so okay rephrase
i'll take it back um we are
no longer talking about our constituent
responsibility or the responsibilities
of
the people of new hampshire and let me
say that i've listened
after listening to this conversation
very few members of this
committee understand the difference
between professional products
and um retail products
they understand very little difference
between
things that you can do at home and
things that you can do in a professional
at a professional education please
represent allegro is making a point of
order that you can't tell him what he
understands
i'm not speaking to him i'm speaking to
the community
she's speaking of the command yes
and i'm expressing my opinion very much
very much like the other members of this
committee
and therefore i tell you that
is not
the um
the purview of this committee we are
here brought
forth by our constituents to represent
them and to do
the thing that that we've been doing to
protect the people of new hampshire
and i this conversation does not lend
credibility to the understanding of this
business of this business of cosmetology
so i'm just telling you that i am i
rarely speak like this i think the
people who know me on this committee
understand that and i think i have some
credibility in this committee
as my second term as someone who's very
reasonable
and somebody who is willing to listen
and talk to people
and see their side of their of their
argument and being collaborative
see where we can agree on this
if we continue in this direction and i
am going to vote against this bill and
i'm going to ask that we retain it
because this is going to be a
conversation that we're going to have
continually
and i would like to have a mutual
understanding
madam chair which is something that you
strive for as well
thank you thank you representative
goalie
thank you madam chair and i too just
want to
reiterate some of the things that were
said and have been said
during this exec session that
this bill that we've heard numerous
times
was about individuals giving haircuts to
their children
i think that was the majority of the
testimony we used to hear
about this bill this bill
goes well beyond addressing that issue
i have no problem defining a family
member or something of that nature
um if we're gonna do it but this is
opening up that whole section of the
statute
to dealing with whether you collect
money or not
that is the difference of what we're
talking about i mean
the majority of the testimony was about
giving haircuts
to family members so if we want to
address that issue let's address that
issue
so i too would be willing to retain it
so we can actually address the issue
that was brought before this committee
and we'll still vote against the ought
to pass
thank you thank you representative
schultz
yes i just want to uh reiterate the
point that um and expand on the point
that representative
uh schmidt said and that this is a bill
in search of a problem it doesn't fix an
issue that's happening
many of us during cove and i made the
joke about my husband's bad hairdos
and i am a horrible hair cutter and i'm
joked that there's a reason why you need
a license for this
um but really this would dismantle the
industry
this would dismantle the um
licensing of this industry
go on some of them if they're good at it
uh to
continue to train others and
it takes years sometimes for a
hairdresser
or an esthetician to build a client list
because they have to prove that they're
good at it
with their continued education with
their continued
updates from uh their organizations
that oversee this profession these
professions
and uh you know people are still going
to be doing
for as long as we're uh many of us
staying at home or self quarantining
the covet haircuts none of us have
gotten in trouble too many of us have
posted the horrible pictures
on the internet and no one called the
police
on me maybe they should have bad
haircuts
but seriously the amount of training and
the amount
of professionalism that this industry
has
in an industry where technically most of
the people who do
it are contracted to do it so there's
essentially in many ways self-employed
this is
an issue around businesses
that people make a livelihood at and
this would decimate that
this would essentially replace all of
that hard work and training
and give a lack of confidence to the
average granite stater that they're even
going to someone who knows the basics
about which chemicals to mix
or are your is your equipment
uh that cuts the cuticles on my toes
gonna give me mrsa
which we need to keep this in industry
intact
it doesn't have the sort of barriers and
roadblocks that
um would actually keep people from doing
it
for any negative reason it's so that
they have the training and understanding
thank you representative lackas um just
a response from earlier comment
i mean i i respect all the members of
this committee and i appreciate
the uh you know collegial
interaction we've had um but
you know i think we are representing our
constituents and there are differences
of opinion
between different people and different
uh areas are different
as to the extent to which um government
should be
controlling what they're doing to what
the extent to which there should be
occupational licensing
and i don't think it's inappropriate for
people to
uh reflect the views of some of their
constituents
thank you all right i think everyone's
had a chance to
speak on this is there anyone who wishes
to
all right seeing none the motion is
ought to pass by representative allegro
on house bill 606
the clerk will call the roll
representative roy
yes clark votes yes representative
pearson
yes
representative yakovich yes
representative lekkis
yes representative allegro yes
representative bailey
yes representative representative
lunzara
yes representative santo nestaso yes
representative goalie no representative
sherwood
oh has represented judy returned
representative fellows no
representative fundo no
representative and adamant
no i believe you skipped representative
schultz
i did skip representative schultz
representative schultz
no representative grota
no representative o'brien nope
and the chair yes okay in this case i
guess
it's um ten to eight
yes
well in that case is someone going to
yes they probably um we have until
monday right
yes definitely will want to write one
all right
who should representative schultz i'm
going to put you on the hook you can
collaborate with anyone you like
okay
l representative schultz i need to
record
absolutely okay two
oh yeah no let's go let's let's get at
least one more before we uh
and we will not be able to finish um
544 until representative judy gets here
so we'll recep so we will recess that
one
uh representative uh ikhubovich would
you care to make a motion
oh yes madam chair
uh i moved to amend uh house bill 155
and the amendment is from representative
edwards
all right so the motion is ought to pass
and he presents amendment number zero
three
nine six house bill 155 to adopt the
i am so sorry what is the amendment
again because i'm going to have to look
at this amendment number zero
three nine six h it's one of the ones
that representative edwards presented
at the hearing oh right thank you and it
declares
august 9th as the international day of
as per the um
the un's
all right do you wish to speak to your
motion um
yes yes thank you uh we've listened to a
lot of testimony
i've learned a lot i remembered a little
bit
history of always interested me
uh gave me a chance to delve into human
migration i have to be a migrant myself
recent times but i learned that the
people
well the humanity originated in africa
and then
spread out throughout the world and
about 14 000 years ago
the human population tribes from
asia went through eurasia went through
siberia
bering straits and arrived in america
and then obviously it took multiple
generations for them to travel
throughout
north america south america they spread
out everywhere
and it took them that long and
up until probably a thousand years ago
nobody else showed up
on this continent and then 500 years ago
columbus and then well i'm one of the
most recent migrants about 30 years ago
so so all these travel stories and
history
fascinated me and i believe that the
people who got
here first definitely deserve a day the
indigenous people they've arrived here
again multiple generations they traveled
and back in 1994
the u.n recognized
these well people the migrants the
travelers the great travelers that
got in here and established that august
9th should be known as the
indigenous people's day and this is why
i'm making the motion
with this amendment and i believe
this is what we should do here in the
committee thank you
thank you representative allegra um i
think that
says everything that needs to be said
and in addition
uh i think it's uh provides a little bit
of satisfaction
for everyone that might be on uh
opposing sides of the uh this debate
so that's why a second and support the
amendment representative schultz
i actually appreciate all the things
especially representative yakubovic said
i
i would love to hear more about your
immigrant
history here in america i think that the
u.n doing
on indigenous peoples uh
holiday or commemoration whatever
it is officially called is though a
uniquely
different thing than what
the sponsors of this bill are trying to
address
um you know there are still multiple
places around the world where
there is no representation at the united
nations
from a variety of matter of fact there's
a group called the
unrepresented people's organization and
i knew some folks that were involved
in it um from the kurdish community
and from uh the palestinian community
i think that though that is just not the
same thing
that the bill authors uh want to
address and as well intentioned as the
amendment is
i would like to suggest that we vote on
the
actual bill itself we've had this bill
a number of times now uh especially the
main sponsor
representative horrigan has expressed
his desire for this not to be amended
and because it is connected to a
specifically american movement
and a new hampshire movement that
specifically wants to
ditch columbus day whether you agree
with it or not
it is a movement to ditch columbus day
for an indigenous people's day
specifically for
new hampshire um and the people who were
here
as representative yakubovic so
eloquently put it
you know sure the land the land bridge
originally asian
eurasian people but uh
they were not discovered by columbus who
never stepped foot on american soil
um nor puerto rican soil etc and
the bill authors definitely want
the vote and the bill to address this
specific
issue not because i had suggested
amendments in the past
but the moment that the lead sponsor
said no
um i don't like your amendment um i
withdrew it
and i think that it would be a
disservice to the intent of this bill
to not just vote on the intent of the
bill as it exists
as written um despite the good
intentions
that's that's all i'm gonna do it's very
nice of you to say so but
it's not his bill anymore it's our bill
and i recommend it
and i and i am sure i am not alone
in having presented a bill that was
significantly changed by the committee
or the house or the senate
it's one of the risks of of putting
forth the bill
can be changed uh representative goalie
and then thank you madam chair and
thank you for that bit of advice because
i was going to also make that statement
that the bill is in our hands now
as a committee um but i also want to
speak to the amendment
um as you know this has come before us
numerous times now um and
was put to a subcommittee to try and
come back with
a day that they chose um and
it's unfortunate that there is a world
recognition world later world
recognition of this
on august 9th um and
i'm not sure why uh they are against
um having this day uh known as
indigenous people's day
i i understand if there is an issue with
the columbus day recognition then
change the name of columbus day
um and not just to indigenous peoples
day when you already
are recognized on august 9th
so i think with this amendment we are
recognizing that day
we have a statute a number of days that
are national days that we recognize as
state days
such as national teachers day we have
that in state statute to recognize that
along with national
teachers day and i think this goes along
with that same precedent that we have
set
so i will support this thank you
representative
there is a national teacher's day or
i've never heard of it i've been in the
game for about 25 years
you are paying attention national
teachers appreciation day yes
oh yeah well terrific i'm appreciated
next
what i want to say is what i'd like to
say is
i may if i can talk a little bit about
the issue
in general i heard last year when this
was discussed
one representative said that we don't
want to be
too far out ahead of our populace
in the sense that we need to do some
education about columbus
i thought that was a very wise thing i
don't know how we go about that by the
way
but that was pretty it was i thought
that pretty
interesting good comment i would be in
favor
having been educated now i'm a committee
of one here
about columbus i just assume get rid of
the name
entirely i'm not sure i i don't want
either of them by the way i just assume
not have any mention of columbus or
indigenous peoples day
personally because but that takes me
down the rabbit hole of debating
indigenous peoples i can probably
support the amendment but i'd like to
see it go farther
and remove the name of columbus
from that day uh i'm not ready to take
up the
the uh man the ramparts for it but
that's how i feel
uh and that's that okay we're not
schmidt
thank you madam chair um so i i would
like to begin by saying
this is a new hampshire bill it's a new
hampshire issue
uh we have uh indigenous people in this
state
who are descendants of of people who
have been here
for 13 or 14 000 years by the scientific
reckonings
um and they were never driven out like
some tribes were
in this southern part of the the east
coast
the so-called trail of tears the story
comes to mind
um but the abunaki and the other
indigenous
people of this area and their
descendants are still here
they weren't driven out they've never
gone there they were here then
they're still here and for those people
columbus day is a an annual slap in the
face
and it's a slap in the face uh
really in many respects of italians as
well
colum christopher columbus is not an
exemplar
of italian culture he is not somebody
who should be celebrated
if there was a lack of understanding at
one point
of his true history
could you continue to speak about the
amendment rather than about columbus day
well uh the amendment doesn't go
in the direction we need to go it it
it's it's a step in the right direction
but the indigenous people
uh who are here they are capable of
celebrating
their own existence uh on their own they
don't need our help
it's columbus day which is an annual
slap in the face so i will not be
supporting the amendment
because it doesn't go where where we
need to go which is to get
rid of christopher columbus celebration
italian culture italian culture is
wonderful
that's where we that that's where we
needed to
also come down a celebration of italian
culture is not accomplished by
thank you madam chair um i'm
all for having recognition of indigenous
people's day
but i don't um think it belongs
with the holidays i looked in the
statutes
to see if i could find some kind of
definition that shows me the distinction
between
making something a holiday and putting
it in the proclamation
list so i i think that
um i'd be happy to see indigenous people
say in a proclamation
i'd be happy to see christopher columbus
day
be taken out of the holidays i'd be
happy to see
an italian recognition
day in the with the proclamations
but adding um this to
the holidays i think makes me
concerned that in the future all of
these
proclamation bills that that we received
this year
will start showing up is um
thank you that's a valid concern
representative o'brien
always a second writer just like this
you have a quick question you know
being new to edna if what is the
technical difference or the implications
of something being a holiday versus a
proclamation
a holiday is frequent is is frequently
a day off from work which is an issue in
terms of
of cost columbus day happens to be a
federal holiday but so
i'm what i'm wondering is with this this
bill has a holiday
but it's not on the same day as columbus
day it's a new day so i mean would this
actually cause it to be a day off of
work or would that have to be
explicit that would have to be explicit
thank you
we had it explicitly one one year i
remember that
uh thank you madam chair uh i think at
this particular time
enough has been said in our past thank
you so much for recognizing me
thank you represent scitec i just want
the record
or to the history to note this is about
as close as i've ever gotten
let's just say yes representative roy
if we were debating uh not the amendment
the bill i i would um
actually support a world or a human
exploration day in the place of columbus
because in my mind
that's what that was about um
exploration and
the need for us to go beyond the next
horizon so
to me it's not really about a man or a
day it's about
the whole thing we should be celebrating
is exploration
um but since we're talking about the
all right everyone else
okay thank you the motion is to adopt
amendment
0396h to house bill 155.
the clerk will call the roll
representative roy
yes the clerk supposes he'll vote yes
representative pearson yes
representative jacob yes
representative aleckus yes
representative allegro
yes representative bailey yes
representative lonzara yes
representative santo nestaso yes
representative goalie yes
yes representative as
representative judy arrived no
representative schultz no
representative fellows no
representative
yes representative broda
yes representative o'brien yes
three nose um
12 um 15
yeses three six
all right 15 3 on the amendment
15 3 and the amendment passes
your motion is ought to pass little
amendment yes please okay
is there a second all right
and roy do you wish to speak to your
motion or
i think enough has been said thank you
i congratulate all right
i i would like to comment that i think
representative roy's
point is very well taken because
regardless of what we might think of
columbus
as a person he did accomplish
connecting the hemispheres and that
changed the world forever
and i think that is something that we
should be
should be noting anyone else have a
comment
question represent a site i'd still like
to see columbus ditched
but i'm not quick
one step at a time one step at a time
represent allegro
we never thought of this as an italian
celebration you might notice by the
battle at the end of my name that i
qualify
and we were never taught in school that
columbus uh
was a great man we were taught that he
was a great explorer
and uh fact remains two facts remain one
is that
uh his exploration changed the course of
human history
and b whether or not he was brutal he
only reflected
humankind in general because there was
savagery and slavery and
brutality uh performed by nations and
tribes on every continent
on the planet so i don't celebrate
christopher columbus
for being a great man in fact i don't
celebrate it at all i just acknowledge
that um
that day is designated to recognize
a great explorer and that's what
christopher columbus was
the other thing of course is that
columbus day in new hampshire
is the official end of the summer
tourist season
and that's when the granite state
ambassadors switch from khaki pants to
tech real quick representative allegro
he was even
beyond the man of the times i mean
we had civilization actually was
occurring and he was just
beyond man that's not necessary i i
think
that there are multiple historical
accounts
and that one has become very popular and
in vogue lately
i think it's greatly mistaken right
okay all right representative
yes madam chair thank you i i just
wanted to say if
representative scitec wants to produce
that bill next session
i will co-sponsor it with him all right
representative schultz okay
there's all this discussion about
columbus but at this point
is there any reference to columbus at
all but given how the amendment is
it's only that he columbus day remains
unchanged in the statutes that is being
amended
because it's confusing that that
actually is a part of the wording
um part of a what it didn't change the
title
i'm sorry i'm just going to be honest to
say that i haven't read the amendment i
just knew i was going to be against it
but
it leave any reference to columbus in
the amendment or the bill as amended if
it
goes back no the title is changed to say
establishing a holiday commemorating
indigenous
people's day and then that is left
as columbus day is left unchanged
along with election day veterans day and
thanksgiving day
that's just what's there already
thank you okay representative
excuse me representative schultz all
that will change next year with
representative
schuetz and my bill right
anyone else i don't think we've
said our piece in that case the motion
is to adopt with amendment
house bill 155 oh and we have
representative judy
joining us excellent ah
let's let's call him in and have him
introduce himself
representative judy would you state your
presence
yes i'm home my wife
is in a room excellent
we are we have the motion now
is ought to pass one amendment on house
bill 155
is he here when the question was put yes
okay uh representative roy
yes claire puts yes representative
pearson
yes representative jacobovic
yes representative lekkis yes
representative allegro
yes representative bailey yes
representative representative alanzara
yes
representative santo nestaso yes
representative goalie
yes representative stuart
yes representative judy
representative schmidt yes
representative fellows yes
representative fontenot yes
representative grota
[Music]
my apologies yes representative o'brien
yes and the chair yes okay
do you object to consent representative
schultz
all right since representative judy is
here
i would like to suggest that we complete
house bill 544
and then declare victories go home
[Music]
so resuming the uh
on 544 we have adopted the amendment
and we already
the motion representative
roy
i moved um house bill 544 ought to pass
amendments
thank you okay we are ready to discuss
this
so when i first saw this
i didn't really understand what it was
about
and i had to do some research and what i
did i was
i was really disturbed to find out what
was being taught
some children and workplaces
that this concept of this critical race
theory
that um that we're making some people
apologize to
other people based on the color of their
skin and i found that
i found that deeply disturbing helping
um and i've heard some people
push back emails and you know this is
about free speech
the funny thing about free speech is
while you're free to say
what you want you're also free to walk
away and not listen to it
and this big targets people who aren't
free to walk away and not listen to it
this is compelled compelled listening
now is should critical race theory
be able to be discussed absolutely um
but you should also have the right to
not
have to listen to it or or walk away
from it
and what we have is we have people that
are in schools or in
places that are threatened terminated if
they don't
listen um it is in fact a theory
um it's not something that's proven
um and i just i found the whole concept
to be disturbing
um in the least that people being made
to do or that children are being able to
stand up in front of a class and
apologize for their whiteness
um i i just it's antithetical to
everything that i've ever been taught
about
treating people equally um but again
i respect the right to have that thought
and if people want to think
tell each other it and even teach it so
long as
it's not mandatory that people have to
listen to it so based on that i think
that it's appropriate that we passed
this bill
and been mandatory teaching this
concept thank you okay
representation
thank you just a question of the chair i
suppose
i'm curious and i apologize if i
did did we get an update
on the sign-ins that have occurred
since we started acting on this bill
if it was in the email i missed it the
sign-ins
the official sign-ins closed at midnight
of the day of the hearing the additional
emails we have all received are up to us
to interpret and count all right so the
account that i had on that days
is what was on the sign in that's that
was people that signed in specifically
other people have chosen to send us
their their thoughts
right thank you and i at my count is
all right
thank you mr chair well
one looks at the language of the bill
and as i said to
the the prime sponsor representative
amman
the statements that are made in the bill
are indisputable that no one is better
or worse
than anyone else because of his or her
age
sex race religious belief or whatever
but the problem is not the the language
of the bill
the problem is that the bill itself is
fundamentally uh not workable
uh and antithetical to uh
the structure that we currently have in
the state of new hampshire in that
school instruction public school
instruction
is in the hands of the
school districts and the school boards
of those districts throughout the state
it's a
local control issue so
what is being taught in the state of new
hampshire or not being taught in the
state of new hampshire
is a local control issue and
in point of fact the the alleged thrust
of the bill
is very broad it's overly broad and
unworkable because
it not only uh would
prohibit the teaching of critical race
theory
uh although it doesn't name critical
race theory but
all the proponents or virtually all the
proponents of the bill
have focused on critical race theory
which may or may not be an
odious uh and a
hostile racist concept
i'm not willing to devote a lot of my
time
into determining what it is the bottom
line is
that the bill goes too far because it
would
in the in the testimony of the aclu
it is unconstitutional and if you look
into it you see that
the executive order on which it is
almost
word for word pattern was struck down
[Music]
just a few months after former president
trump
issued the executive order so the bill
if it were passed
it would almost certainly be immediately
enjoined
and likely struck down as being too
vague
overly broad and so forth and so on so
the problem is that no one
denies or very few people would deny
that we still have
problems with discrimination in this
state
as well as in the nation we still have
problems with
racism ageism sexism and so forth
um so the fact that the bill
i know prohibits uh
discussion of those issues but the
problem is it goes too far
and would not uh
be acceptable under our constitution
in my opinion and the testimony that we
heard and we heard
that from the from the new hampshire uh
school as a
school administrators association in
opposition
uh i've already talked about the fact
that it's a local issue
but above and beyond that and more
importantly is
critical race theory and i've checked
into this critical race theory
is not being taught in the state of new
hampshire
certainly is not being taught at the
at the elementary school level and the
courses that are taught
are very often not only well-intentioned
but well-designed courses
to deal with the issues of slavery
racism sexism ageism and so forth
and they likely would also come into
conflict with this statute
if it were adopted and enacted so the
the bill is simply not a good idea it's
too broad
it engages issues that it doesn't intend
to engage
uh and what we should do especially
since
uh critical race theory is not really uh
widespread in new hampshire if it's if
it's being used
at all what we should be doing with this
bill is retaining it
and looking at the issue because unlike
the pandemic which started in
apparently in china and there
then very swiftly got to our shores both
east and west coast
and have spread everywhere
this is not something that's like a
pandemic
this is something which is clearly a
matter of choice
and whatever state one may
encounter crt critical race theory
it's not an issue in new hampshire nor
is it inevitable
and in point of fact our schools are
dealing with the real issues
the issues of racism and sexism and so
forth
um and critical race theory is not
being promulgated being taught or
being is you know spread around the
state of new hampshire
there's no urgency about getting this in
to stop this evil
practice from from from contaminating
our state
it's not here and there's no
likelihood given my discussions with
school authorities
that it will that it will be adopted in
our local schools
whatsoever because it is very
controversial at the very least and
counterproductive
based on the research i've done so
we are again in search of
of a unless of a problem with this
solution
which is not workable and it's almost
certain to be enjoined
if it ever gets through the senate and
or gets signed by the governor
which i strongly doubt thank you
representative smith
just for the record indicate that the
the bill does not
prohibit discussion of race racism or
anything of the sort that
prohibits the things outlined in
critical race theory
um representative allegro yeah i would
like to point out that
the title of this bill is divisive
concepts
in fact the term critical race theory is
not even mentioned in it so
arguing that critical race theory is not
a problem
um really is not germane so what is
germain to this bill
is racism uh which i and i hope
everybody here
i've looked online to pick up the oxford
american webster definition
of racism words and definitions do still
have
meaning and weight it says prejudice and
of shortening is prejudice
discrimination or antagonism against
a person or people on the basis of their
membership in a particular
official or a group well that is exactly
what and i don't use critical risk areas
but i mean all of its uh allied
hypotheses
that's exactly what they teach they
to use street jargon it keeps
misbehavior of all of humankind
on the backs of one race uh
one group and that's uh
principally white men of european
descent
by definition that is racism
i hope that uh the whole committee will
join me in a hoarding racism
and by the way um this is not
a an issue of uh uh first
segment uh restriction of free violation
uh we live in our dead eyes now
with restrictions on our first amendment
in all sorts of venues
for instance and in all of our behaviors
we are not allowed
to express racism in equal opportunity
institutions most required by law
or in housing or in curriculum
i'm sure that if our school curriculum
taught that
all african americans are
to blame for some particular ill in
society
that there would be little to no
objection but that's
actually the way it is now uh you will
have your money
sucked out belong to you by the state
the federal government
if you attempted to propose that
hypothesis
white black yellow right
no one's teaching our children they are
as we've heard testimony they are
teaching our children
uh that white people are shameful
racist bigots and that they're the only
one
and it's just wrong no matter what color
you are i
i believe in martin luther great
statements
thank you mr chair and i i go along with
representative schmidt's comments um i
won't go on long uh but i just do want
to
of the bill that still i think we heard
in testimony
could be or is unconstitutional by
requiring
uh contractors with states telling them
what they can and cannot
do uh with their employees and with
their own private dollars
um and i i for that reason i cannot
support this bill
um i i think we had strong testimony on
that
and with that still in the bill there is
a problem
and like representative schmidt i think
it will be ruled unconstitutional
thank you thank you uh
representative um representative
judy you can go now or you can go yes
thank you thank you mr chair you hear me
quickly
yes we hear you well thank you all right
thank you thank you mr chair
uh hb 544
this bill is an attack
on first amendment rights attack
directly
a category of people after all bad
souvenirs
right now we need a healing bill
not a divided one like this
actually new hampshire has a diversity
population i am one of them
who does not have a voice
i am firmly opposed this racist bill
members of the committee please
put this bill each ideal
please i am urging you
to oppose this racist bill
the passage of this bill will detract
not contribute we need to go forward
not backward i remember
two years ago uh
we tried to bring something uh about
slavery and stuff like that clearly
our our share
honourable troy
take it roy tell you why i said
why you have to bring all those by
souvenir
so i never forgot that so
mr chair please
don't pass this bill i am deeply
concerned
the unborn members
republicans we can do better than that
we are here to make a difference
for our beautiful state not to harm
bisexual or transgenders
all of us we are children of god
the creator the unique creator
he loves you he loves black gene
judy the same way
yes we try to divide the country
we try to divide uh human beings
but god asked us
the creator he asked us to
is the worst crime
we're not going to come back in slavery
again
we're not going to come back
right now you see china
the stayed live in china they vote
kids have to go to school seven days a
week
you know why because
they want to become the greatest
if we try to go back
we we are going uh to wasting our time
and by the time we wasting those times
china will be the greatest not
between kids and kids in school
about in france members of the committee
i urge you to defeat this racist bill
what we need in new hampshire is peace
and love peace and love
we need in new hampshire equality
for identity for all
god our creator asked us
to love one another
he didn't he didn't talk about this he
didn't talk about
cola he asked us
for love
i am the man of god i don't believe
representative ghouli is super good in
me
white global members
are more than me i never think like that
and i don't believe in those things i
believe in love
i believe in respect i believe
in fidelity because
we are in this earth we have an example
right now in nasa
you seen perseverance
in the mosque you see what shanna doing
now
he's saying some some something up there
in mass to take pictures and next time
you will see china go inside the match
like
this by the time
we are playing black and white black and
white
sport for several years
dr martinez junior brain
and leave us a lesson to learn
you cannot judge gene judy because he's
black
no you have to you have to judge me
because of my character
you have to judge me since 2005
i've been there and idiot
until today so don't wait
when jin judy passed away to tell my
wife and my kids and my grandkids
and my daughter-in-laws oh gene was a
good man
oh respectful man no you have to respect
me right now
by the time i'm alive here i have
seven grandchildren i can tell you
makes children white and black
if you pass this bill you're going to
hurt me not only personally
but this generation and generation
you're going to have
so it's not easy to be
married but
i see it's easier
for some white people i don't say all
for some white people
to be happy to try another race down
but remember all of you
there is a creator remember all of you
god is watching us
i like reading i saw black
spanish haitians chinese
go on a vegas go with them i don't see
any superior
i don't see any superman
because we are the same thing
you cannot judge me because of my
quarrel
you can judge me by my act
the way i act in the society the way i
react in the society
but be smart don't pass this bill
i pledge allegiance to the flag
of the united states of america and to
the republic
for which we spend one nation
under god indivisible with liberty
and justice for all not justice for some
thank you representative judy just for
the record regardless of how the vote
goes i i love you man
representative scitec um
no one can disagree with anything that
representative judy has said
i wanted to speak more to the bill and
uh
representative goalie i understand about
the contractors i'm looking at this from
the prism of the teacher who wants to be
appreciated i guess
and that's for me this bill is symbolic
uh it sends a signal that the classroom
is for teaching anything you want to
teach but it is the classroom
is not for indoctrination um
and i don't see this i see this being
law if it were a law being invoked any
more
than a father being indicted for cutting
his son's hair
so that's all i have to say
okay i actually written my remarks down
which i so rarely do
and i've also chosen my words very
carefully i want to be clear i'm not
disparaging anyone personally in what
i'm about to say
i'm focusing on the content of the bill
this bill is an awful product of the
race-baiting dog whistle
politics of the trump era and the fake
battle against cancel culture
but this isn't just some cut and paste
of an executive order
this actually signals an embrace of
trump's bigoted
i am afraid that is a bit inflammatory
and since it is not a copy of the
executive order
it is a separate bill please
tone down your remarks well i want to be
able to address
the specifics of the bill because i
don't think he was attacking don't
mention don't mention ex president trump
um well that's hard because that's where
this movement has come from but let me
i think that's my only other mention of
him
um i will say
there has been a rise not specifying
when or who
of anti-semitism sexism homophobia
and white supremacy in the common
discourse
um i suspect most of us know
that were this bill to be signed by the
governor it will be declared
unconstitutional
i suspect most of us know this bill will
never become law
so why do it at all is it really worth
it to throw red meat
in an albeit large segment of
republicans
to take the side of a small segment of
ultra conservative activists
over the inherent bias training that is
so
mainstream it is laughable to put
a fake battle over cancel culture ahead
of the urgent need to face
racism head on with an honest albeit
often awkward
society-wide conversation about our
differences
or is it that good old game of divide
and distract
today happens to also be the day in a
different committee
when a very popular minimum wage bill hb
517 is being put forward which i also
happen to be the lead sponsor
does hb 544 distract
oh there's trump's name again i was
going to say the racist relic of the
trump era but i won't say that
it gets more inc and airplay than this
bill or does the minimum wage bill
get less inc than this bill which i
believe
the minimum wage is also
supported by most republican
rank-and-file voters overwhelmingly
one can deny it but we all know racism
is really in america
we all know which of our neighbors or
colleagues or members of our families
hold
blatantly racist views and the blatant
example of systemic racism
are do not undeniably on horrific
display in america
from the deaths of george floyd and
taylor say their names to the
separations in our neighborhoods with
the remnants of redlining
to all the significant disparities
and all the statistics from unemployment
to covet deaths
to infant mortality systemic racism is
unfortunately
alive and everywhere including in new
hampshire
at its roots all race really reflects
is where our ancestors are from and how
much
melanin is in our skin i ask you dear
colleagues
please kill this bill do the right thing
and vote against
uh ought to pass so itl
can get the majority of our votes thank
you
thank you representative schultz i
believe you've been hearing your floor
speech
uh representative fellows oh schuett
excuse me she would just first
thank you madam chair um i will just
briefly state that
i am of the opinion that has been
expressed by a few of my colleagues that
this bill will not pass constitutional
muster
uh i would also point out to the chair
that we all witnessed a member of the
committee in the room
violating the mass distancing policy
i would just call that to the chair's
attention
thank you representative fellows
thank you madam chair just a few minutes
for my thoughts
slavery was abolished 150 years ago
but does anyone doubt that racism is
still
alive and well in this country and this
state
in 2020 we saw many examples of racism
ahmad aubry the jogger shot dead when he
stopped for a moment to look at the
progress of a home under construction
i've done that before would those men
have shot me
a black teenager in a new york hotel
attacked by a woman who had lost
her iphone if i had been standing there
with the iphone
would she attacked me the newest trend
in racism seems to be attacking asian
americans who are just walking down the
street
what will be next if passing a law would
eliminate racism i would vote for it
but no law will cure our problem of
racism
the only way to cure racism and other
forms of bias
is for everyone to really understand
where and how it exists and to know what
it feels like to be on the receiving end
what we need is more education in
dialogue
about racism not less we need to
encourage
not stifle teaching about racism
at all educational levels it should be
woven throughout the curriculum
in ways that are age-appropriate and i
trust our teachers to do that
everyone deserves to feel safe to be
treated with dignity
and to have equal access to a quality
education
job opportunities housing loans
and business mentorships for this to
come about we need to talk about
racism i will vote against this bill
because it is an unconstitutional
restriction
on free speech and will inadvertently
protect racism rather than condemning it
thank you madam chair just very briefly
for me while there
may be numerous reasons to uh
oppose this bill as a member of the edna
committee i will oppose it
simply because i have tremendous respect
for representative judy
thank you all right thank you
is there anyone else who wishes to speak
representative roy i just want to
reiterate what i said from the beginning
i i would not be voting for this bill if
it prohibited the discussion of racism
the teaching of the
struggles of different races in our
history this bill does nothing of the
sort this bill only prohibits racist
teachings
um so i will continue to support it and
as i said i love representative judy
but um i i do not love the the teachings
that
anyone else representative schultz
thank you um i do just want to uh
address
uh that point because i think it's
important to understand
you know there's a sort of well this is
the only word that's coming to mind and
i do not mean it as a as
there's a whitewashing of this
discussion upon
absolutely unintended um
that really to me and i believe to many
folks
is the accidental uh step cousin twice
removed of holocaust denial
to approach racism the way this bill
does
is absolutely censorship um
and to approach it in a way that assumes
wrongly
that somehow white children are being
told they're racist
it's absolutely not the truth this
this bill isn't needed this thank you
for that comment representative schultz
all right representative scitec if i
thought any of this was true i would
vote against this bill
i just don't read it the way you do and
that's enough
yes anyone else
thank you in that case the motion is
ought to pass
with amendment on house bill 544
and the clerk can call the world
representative
representative roy yes rep the clerk
yes representative yakovich
yes representative yes representative
allegro
yes representative bailey yes
represent representative lonzara yes
representative santo nestaso yes
representative golin no representative
sherwood
absolutely not representative judy
no wait representative schultz
no representative
schmidt no representative fellows
no representative no
representative grota no
representative bryant no
and the chair yes good night
all right i'm surprised uh
the motion is adopted
is there to be a minority report
um has not been determined yet i will
let you know
this afternoon i'll put you down as
okay
i think all representatives
who vote against this bill
we know we are not voting against this
belonging
i'm sorry i'm not catching what you're
saying it's my fault i'm sure but i
you hear me yes i can hear you
okay uh i'm going to say that again i
think
all of you who would know for this bill
not only for jin judy for my kids and my
grandkids
and anything happened in new hampshire
remember all of you who vote yes
for this bill you take your
responsibility
and don't be sorry
when those things start going wrong here
in new hampshire
i've been here since 1983
i never see a fight between black and
white
even kids at school in elementary school
high school
and university uh
sometimes kids they can fight with their
kids
like i used to fight in catholic school
when i was in haiti everybody is black
we fight in the soccer soccer team
soccer players
but this bill take the note
this this bill going to create something
so you take your responsibility
take your responsibility to know when
those things start coming
to let yourself know your conscience
to say i am responsible for those things
happening
because not only this bill
is unconstitutional and this bill
also is a racist bill
and i'm going to say thank you to
all of you who voted against israel
uh without the fortner thank you very
much
and i'm going to say the last word
representative tell you why remember
we love each other remember that we love
each other thank you madame chair
i want to throw something in i know
you're weary of hearing me talk about
being in high school but i look very
hard
i watch we have more we don't have very
many blacks in our school we have
fair number of uh muslims are people
appearing that way and i just don't
see it i'm really watching
i don't hear bullying i i i i don't live
in
lake wobegon the cure for this is when
all
of this dies out we can't educate
true racists we can posture we can give
them training it's not going to happen
they have to die out the way smokers the
way
i'm even wearing a seat belt and i when
i drove there was no such
thing i resisted it i wear them
this is a representative fellows is on
to something
with talking about education yeah
people just mingle in our school i don't
see it
representative fellows we can represent
schultz both want to rebut
me
thank you madam chair i i just want to
say to representative scitec
that it is out there and i have i have a
black friend who tells me he's
he he runs into it all the time
you just you just don't know because
you're not like you might maybe you're
not
you don't have friends that are black
you don't talk to people who are black
and ask them about this this is what
what training bias training is about so
people understand that it really is
out there and in terms of letting it
just die
out it's been 150 years it didn't die
out yet it's not going to die out
anytime
soon unless we all work together to do
something about it
yes that's true we all work together
that's because of our education it will
die out
let's not root for it to continue
um i'm sorry since we have completed the
vote
and had a number of speeches on this i
think i will
not entertain any more speeches on the
uh
madam chair i just was going to tell a
quick story about a racist who undid
their racism
i i hope you will be able to share that
in a more cheerful moment
it sounds like a good story oh please
so tell it this was from in response to
rep scitec because he said
racism a racist never
uh get over being a racist i will just
say
growing up in the south uh one part of
my family is very racist
the other part of my family fantastic
and i spent more time with them
love them i love all my family by the
way
and my brother adopted two children
one from romania because they thought
that he would look more like
us turns out he's of the roma people and
is a person of color
and my niece from guatemala a latina
so no one talked about it but in the
back of my head i'm thinking oh
please let the rest of my family
embrace my niece and nephew
and they're wonderful they've grown up
to be wonderful adults
and as would happen at a family function
without even realizing it one of my
relatives
started spouting off saying a bunch of
racist stuff in front of my niece and
nephew
i grabbed that relative pulled him to
the hallway
and i said have you noticed
the skin color of your niece
and nephew and it had never occurred to
them
but i do know from that moment on our
conversations around race were radically
different
i wish for that for everybody that are
racist
important because of our differences
and i'll leave it at that all right
thank you
it's it's just it's after one o'clock
and i personally am beginning to get a
headache for lunch
for not having had lunch so i'm going to
close the official part of the meeting
and leave the zoom open for for those of
you who wish to make further comments to
do so
i would like to thank everyone um should
everyone should experience the the
military service because when i joined
the service the first thing i learned is
that we were all
equally worthless and
nobody was better facing their race and
i learned to put my hands
that my life in the hands of other
people of different colors and they
me and by the end of it
you know the only color i saw was green
all right schmidt still wants to sauce
are we taking a are we taking a lunch
break or are we
done for the day on bills we're done for
the day
we've accomplished it quite a bit
actually and
we will be meeting again on monday
with continue
on the youth advisory council and
one house bill 141
thank you and uh representative uh
schultz i mean when we're back to uh
meeting in person i'll be glad to
continue the discussion over at tammy's
with your delight
i would welcome that i think uh i've
always loved serving on this committee
and there's a few of you haven't met yet
i welcome that i think that would be
good
i think we've met but we didn't have
much of a chance to talk who's buying
yes i do remember you
representative like this i do and your
wife too she loves to hug
yes she does yeah that's how she's uh
she does hard but not as much as before
with this code thing so she's
you know my filling in doesn't quite